this video contains some cut content
that i feel you need to know about giant
heads in limb grave cut quest lines and
so much more the community's data miners
have made some really legendary
discoveries in the past few months and
it's just incredible how many things lie
just out of sight
blythe's tower in the mistwood ruins for
example is properly set up to be a
destructible object although it's been
tweaked to prevent it being destroyed
this might point to an earlier design
concept for blythe's questline where you
might have had to use the nearby bear to
crush the tower and bring blythe down to
you
of course this might have led to
problems
sometimes it's easy to figure out why
content was cut but sometimes it's
really difficult for example have a
listen to this recreated encounter with
a semi a silver tier npc that was cut
from the game and first appears begging
you not to kill her please wait
proud tarnished warrior
before you kill me
let me speak
i am a semi
my true form is that of a silver tear i
am a simple being
who can assume the shapes of other
living things
but now
i've gained knowledge
i speak
and ponder
and live
in fear of death
oh
mighty
tarnished warrior
i beg of you
let me keep the life i've been granted
in exchange
i offer you power
oh thank you
now
set your lips upon me
and breathe in deep i will live inside
of you
and grant you strength untold
onward
to our glorious future my host
melania also has something to say about
this is there
another person inside of you did you
want that to happen
i sense no malice
do as you think best
hello
other you
i am malina
and i am traveling with this person
we might be together for some time
pleased to meet you once inside you it
seems a simi would stay quiet that is
until you arrive in the eternal cities
where it sounds like she would speak up
and ask you to seek out two chalices she
needs these to quench her thirst and
rejuvenate her flesh once you drink from
both chalices you supposedly awaken to
hear this ah
are you awake
we've become a perfect [ __ ]
now there's definitely a sinister aspect
to this quest as well and this character
somehow it seems you could find your
other self and confront them oh
you found me
i had hoped you wouldn't
you could have become elden lord
and i could have become sovereign
eternal
eventually if you hadn't found me
we both could have been lords
after this fight we have to assume that
it's here where you would originally
have received the mimic tear spirit
ashes and wouldn't this quest be such a
better way to get the mimic tier ashes
this summon ended up being so powerful
and so game defining that it just really
did define the late game playthroughs of
many players and i include myself among
them in my opinion if there's going to
be something this experience defining in
the game it would be great if it had a
difficult and interesting questline
associated with it at least but who
knows maybe this questline will find its
way into the game via a patch or dlc so
the purpose of this segment is really
just to let you know that i see me
existed but if you want to learn more
about this questline then the user
nullrin on youtube has done a much
better recreation of it than i have and
the modder securo doobie is planning on
doing a complete restoration of the
quest line within the game so be sure to
subscribe to them for that
and that brings us as always with these
videos to lance and to his restoration
of another cut questline perhaps you've
heard of dream brew
the nectar of the demigods once
forbidden to immortals
well
believe it or not
i know just how to make it
this man is known as rico and through
talking with him you're given an item
called saint trina's crystal ball and
then you're tasked with using it to
collect dream mist from sleeping enemies
you might recall these sleeping wolves
and bears and even land octopi they were
actually present in the 2021 network
test version of eldon ring and with the
hacked crystal ball in your inventory we
can go back and see the dense fog of
sleep that is around these creatures and
we can even siphon some of it for our
own
with two of these dream mists in your
inventory we can return to rico and we
can claim our dream brew but what does
dream brew do
well according to rico dream brew is
imbibed to give you a reprieve from this
crumbling world and it can even be used
to uncover someone's deepest darkest
secrets a pleasure as ever old friend
the secret the dialogue reveals here is
that kalei you know like all wandering
merchants is haunted by visions of the
frenzied flame
so while getting a few extra lines of
dialogue from npcs isn't particularly
rewarding you know i think it would be
really cool if we could use dream brew
to actually physically enter npc dreams
like we do with fear during her
questline regardless i still think the
dream brew quest line is pretty cool it
encourages you to keep an eye out for
sleeping enemies as you explore the
world and it rewards the attentive
player lance has reactivated this early
part of the questline over on his
channel so go and check that out
although i do want to say rico's quest
line does seem to continue after this he
goes into the haleg tree and he has a
lot to do with saint trina
who we're definitely going to talk about
another time
but there's still more that we can learn
from the old network test version take
this for example look back at the low
detail view of limgrave from margate's
arena and you can just make out these
giant smoldering shapes
here lance sends his free cam over and
he discovered these
giant burning stone heads that are
rendered in insanely high detail some of
you might even remember seeing one of
these heads in the earliest known leaks
of eldon rings gameplay back in march of
2021 and we can only really speculate on
what these heads represent
clearly they were giants of some kind
and their closest kin seem to be the
giants that you find in caled and the
giants that you find in the mountaintops
of the giants but even these really
humanoid giants they're still a mystery
who were they
interestingly in another piece of cut
content radan was at one point called
the giant slayer so that might help to
explain why giants are dead in his
region of caled at least but these are
still a mystery
clearly a lot has changed since earlier
versions of elden ring especially when
it comes to the in-game map and these
are changes that continue in every
single patch unseen by many
but of course not much gets past
illusory wall who has been documenting
all of the changes to the in-game map
you should go and watch his full video
but the part i found most interesting in
his video is that even in the current
version of the game the path to jarburg
remains on the map even though the path
is physically not there so i wonder is
this an intentional decision buy from
software to make players want to find
another path to this hidden town
or is it an oversight that they've yet
to fix
i also wanted to mention we're going to
be visiting this town on the channel
really soon prepare to cry
so in my last video we talked about the
law of radar and how he originally
learned gravitational magic in order to
allow him to ride his scrawny horse but
zuli has datamined another little detail
that makes his story hit just a little
bit harder she learned the name of his
horse and that name is leonard
we know this because riddhan's ai is
named radhan and leonard it counts him
and the horse together though we've also
recently learned that they might not
have always fought as one the data
suggests that at one point at least it
might have been planned for leonard to
act as a separate entity to radhan
perhaps you could knock radon off his
horse or even kill leonard as terrible
as that sounds and man if they let us
kill leonard i feel like i'd be able to
make one hell of a prepare to cry
episode i'm just saying
for this next one we have to go back way
back to 2015 when early screenshots of
dark souls 3's alpha version were first
leaked in this screenshot we saw a
concept with a sun leaking darkness but
next to that there was this giant
abyssal snake creature
and then when dark souls 3 finally
released in 2016 data miners found the
ai boss name snake soul in the files and
at this point we speculated that snake
soul might have once been the name of
this giant abyssal creature
there were abyssal snake-like creatures
in the ringed city dlc after all and
that served as even more proof when the
dlc came out but finally with the
release of eldon ring we finally have
the final piece of the puzzle so this is
an ulcerated tree spirit and its a.i
name reveals that it is indeed the
long-lost snake soul and considering its
model has elements taken from dark souls
3's passive man it seems pretty likely
that this is the final concept of a
creature that we first looked at over
seven years ago
so for this next one i want to talk
about godric who was sadly left out of
my last demigods video so let's give him
some screen time there's actually some
of his cut dialogue that really speaks
to his character a bit more in this cut
dialogue he gives a speech which almost
sounds like a rallying cry or a poem
that he's reciting for his followers you
would have heard a small part of this
when he died but this is how the full
thing goes
one day we'll return together
to our home bathing rays of gold
there is only one tree and only its
branches
that bathe in true rays of gold
not the full omen king
nor the rank malformed twins
oh we are the golden ones the true and
rightful heirs
our land's grown old now ashen and cold
but look up
the ur tree glows
one day we'll return together
to our home bathed in rays of gold
and grace will surely guide us safe
to our home
bathed in rays of gold
special thanks to securo dubi who
provided the visuals for this cut
dialogue
similarly godfrey 2 has cut dialogue as
well and his sounds like it would have
been given to the tarnished before they
even journeyed to the lands between have
a listen
elden ring
eldon ring
shaper of life
arbiter of fate
lord of the very stars above
tarnished warrior
spurned by the grace of gold
seek that which hath been lost to thee
across the sea of fog to the lands
between
seek the elden ring
for this last secret i want to talk
about the colosseums so you might have
noticed a few of these scattered
throughout the world there's three in
total one in lane dell
one in limgrave and one in caled in the
law it's here that ritual combat once
took place and these were trials held to
honor the erd tree
however it seems like this practice
might have been more of a thing when
godfrey was around and by the time of
radigan this practice was said to have
died out indeed the doors to this
coliseum are closed even to us
that said it's still possible to get
inside but then youtuber sakiru dubi has
done even more than that and they've
restored a few more elements giving us a
hint at what the arena might once have
been
in the arena itself enemies named
gladiator large and old lion of the
arena fight in gladiatorial combat but
before you get here there's a location
near the entrance called the reception
desk this makes me think that players
might have once been able to open an
interface here you know like you do in
previous games before you enter the
arena but what the player might actually
use these arenas for is still a mystery
could they open up to us in upcoming dlc
if so what would we do inside would we
fight each other in pvp that seems to be
the most likely option from software do
have a habit of adding pvp arenas in dlc
but this could also be a place maybe
where you re-challenge bosses
refighting bosses was a fantastic piece
of dlc that they added to secure and it
would be super welcome in this game as
well
but what do you think
thank you for watching and before you go
i want to talk a little bit more about
audible who kindly sponsored this video
if you go to
audible.com or text varividia to 500 500
then you can claim your free 30-day
audible trial and get full access to
thousands and thousands of audio books
original entertainment series and
podcasts as well that are all included
in the plus catalog additionally you'll
get credit for one full audio book when
you sign up completely free
and this month i'm recommending that you
download the audiobook for a game of
thrones which is obviously the first
title in the now famous series by george
r.r martin who himself had a part in
creating elden ring's story have a quick
listen he was a veteran of a hundred
rangings by now and the endless dark
wilderness that the southern's called
the haunted forest had no more terrors
for him
until tonight
so i tend to use audible when i'm doing
chores or repetitive tasks it kind of
gives a bit more value and meaning to
those moments of downtime so remember go
to
audible.com or text vati video to 500
500 and get your free trial started
today so thank you again to audible for
sponsoring this video and thank you for
watching
you